reaction Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett along with Harvard Law Professor
Alan dershwitz uh Greg will'll begin
with you tonight you've been following
this story you've been writing column
after column uh I want to go to the
heart of this issue I have been calling
this the Joe Biden bribery and money
laundering Scandal allegations uh does
this take us one step closer tonight to
to Joe Biden the president and his
involvement and his lying to the
country it does his complicity Sean the
evidence is mounting that Joe Biden as
you say actively aided and eded his
son's schemes he's been lying about it
all along and everybody knows that even
lied about it
yesterday there there's documents
testimony White House logs emails text
messages that prove that he talked by
phone with Hunter's clients he met
personally with his sons overseas
partners he even attended their meetings
that were closely guarded uh you know
Joe Biden appears to be complicit in
pushing the Biden brand which was
selling access to him Promises of
influence Devin Archer confirmed that
Joe sent signals and operated as
leverage for all of that money millions
of it so it's obvious that Hunter was
selling his dad to the world and the
family was getting rich from it it
doesn't matter whether Joe pocketed a
single penny of it under the bribery
statute is still a crime if the money
goes to any other person or entity other
than the public office holder and of
course as you pointed out earlier
bribery is an impeachable offense and by
the way uh there's no statute of
limitations uh on impeachment as there
were in some of the charges that David
Weiss allowed to lapse intentionally
Professor dtz I I doubt you would
disagree with us on the issue of Joe
Biden lying it is now clear that he lied
to the country when he said he never
spoke to his son brother or anybody uh
for that matter about their father
foreign business dealings but it's
bigger than that because hunter in his
own laptop the very real laptop not not
the fake laptop that the media claimed
uh but he implicates his father half his
income he complain goes to pops uh he
had to pay for pops's home repairs that
is backed up by emails we learned this
week with Hunter I'm sorry with Joe
Biden himself directly with Eric Sherwin
who was the money person in the
corporation uh and then of course emails
with Hunter and Eric Sherwin oh what
account should I pay pops's home repair
bill this time complaining Hunter
complaining about paying the home repair
bills for 11 years uh and then of course
Tony balinsky the big guy money set
aside for this uh none of this would be
happening but for Joe Biden but if you
focus on one issue uh Professor this is
what stands out in my mind Hunter Biden
said he had no experience in energy oil
gas uh coal or Ukraine now if you look
at the barisma example he's paid
millions in that case we know Joe Biden
Le leveraged a billion dollars then we
have that what's at message this
involves CFC that is the Chinese oil
conglomerate again no experience and
energy I'm sitting here with my father
we're wondering why you did not fulfill
your commitment uh between
uh everybody he will use everybody he
knows of my ability to hold a grudge you
will regret not following through with
what you agreed to few days later $5
million shows up in one of those bank
accounts uh Professor uh what James comr
is calling shell corporations tell me
Professor what does that look like to
you well first of all let's remember
who's responsible for all of this coming
out we have to give credit to judge Nora
judge Nora made sure that this was not
all covered up by a deal that made no
fence uh since I predicted on your show
and other shows that judge Nora would
not accept the deal I was trashed for it
by many academics by CNN by many other
media but she did the right thing she
sent it back and the result has been now
much more information coming out to the
American public as I've said before
I hope that this results in the
appointment of a real real special
counsel outside the justice department
looking at the president of the United
States because if it becomes just an
impeachment concern then half the
country won't believe it half the
country will the same thing happened
with Trump but if there's a special
counsel who's credible and who can get
to the bottom of this and either clear
President Biden or accuse President
Biden I think the American public will
Professor let me stop you here
though because we we have Merck Garland
by the way contradicted by David Weiss
and David Weiss contradicted by meric
Garland uh by The Whistleblower
testimony originally we know that Mr
Weiss planned on bringing no charges
that evolved into that sweetheart deal
with no time spent in jail that fell
apart in front of that that judge that
you rightly praise uh who said to the uh
prosecutors you've never seen a deal
like this before for okay Pro
prosecutors had to admit no they never
did okay now we're back at the drawing
board but Merrick Garland then appoints
the guy that allowed the statute of
limitations on the very important tax
years of the barisma money to expire now
why would he why would he appoint that
individual who also contradicted what he
himself Merck Arland said Merck gin said
he had given the authority to Mr Weiss
to press charges and other jurisdictions
well according to the whistleblowers who
took contemporaneous notes they said
David Weiss said just the opposite so
why would he be appointed Unless somehow
they're looking to protect the
bidens well that's why we need to have a
special prosecutor who's above reproach
my suggestion has been that a group of
very distinguished people recommend five
people to Garland and tell him to pick
from those five people nobody from
inside the justice department nobody
Who's involved in Poli ICS people of the
stature of archal Cox who was the
special prosecutor appointed in the
Nixon case everybody believed that what
we need to do is restore credibility to
our criminal justice system not make our
Criminal Justice System into a
weaponized you can you explain Professor
you're you're so you're such a smart man
and you're an honest man can you explain
to this country tonight how it's
possible that somebody that is
admittedly addicted to drugs and alcohol
some some that has no experience is
making millions of dollars from all of
these these countries and even our top
number one geopolitical foe um why would
they be paying him that kind of money if
he has no experience does that make any
sense to you uh Professor because it
doesn't make sense to me oh it makes
complete sense they wanted access to the
president it's called the American
system of lobbying you pay people to
give you access there's no doubt that he
was not qualified to have any of these
positions there's no doubt but let's
look at it legally is are they then
paying for influence and is that a crime
Professor well they're paying for
influence that's clear it's a crime for
the person paying for the influence
whether it's a crime for the person who
was to be influenced that's something
that has to be let me press you further
when Joe Biden went against Obama policy
on the billion in loan guarantees and he
leveraged to get the prosecutor
investigating barisma fired in 6 hours
after he had spoken with those
Executives 5 days earlier with his son
when they were in Dubai together uh and
in fact son of a be he got that guy
fired my question to you is did he Tak
an official action as vice president and
that resulted in a financial gain for
his own son and if he did what would you
call that Greg Jared I think called it
bribery if I'm wrong correct me remember
it's beyond the statute of limitations
now you don't have a statute of
limitations and impeachment but can you
impeach a president who committed an
impeachable offense while vice president
that's an interesting issue what do you
think Greg
Jarrett well look it's barisma as you
have explained is exhibit in bribery 18
USC 2011 and also under the impeachment
clause in the Constitution but there's
far more than that investigators have
tracked at least 24 million from Beijing
sent to Hunter then funel through this
Labyrinth of shell companies and
eventually to his family members that
figure is actually a fraction of the
total cash Hall factor in millions from
China Millions from Ukraine Kazakhstan
Romania half a dozen other countries
over which Joe Biden exerted influence
you're probably closer to $50 million
banked by the bidens in these suspected
influence pedaling schemes I I think
frankly you know the committee has only
spent a few months uncovering mountains
of evidence but it may just be the tip
of the iceberg uh this may be the
largest bribery influence pedaling
scandal in American political history
and shameful do you agree with that
Professor if the evidence supports what
the investigations have shown by Greg by
John Solomon and and by you there is a
Smoking Gun here and that's why we need
a special prosecutor to look into this
because this may be a very very
significant matter but we have to get
the evidence it can't be based just on
allegations and it can't be based on
partisan investigations the American
public deserves to have a person of
great integrity and reputation look into
these matters
but what we know now you admit this is
influence pedaling based on what we know
the facts we know the words of Joe Biden
the words of Hunter Biden I have no
experience uh son of a be they fired him
uh we know what the policy was we know
when the phone calls took place uh
pretty damning if you ask me Professor
but I do appreciate you being with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else